hello the Internet you've joined us very
lair night the only David sleeping and
in this video we're going to experiment
with different colored flames there are
debt there multiple ways to change the
current flame and now we're going to use
Tiki oil tea Easter is lamp oil
basically when we were doing the fire
breathing video I noticed that you can
buy these in different colors so we got
blue and green tea coils to get red and
we're going to use just normal orange
color flames as well you get just a
regular box standard flame bog-standard
glow and we're going to see if we'll get
some nice you know different color shots
that maybe merging together a little bit
rainbow flame sounds good to me
alright let's whip out the phantom
filming high-speed and dark is insanely
difficult you can't see anything uh see
we'll say okay let's heat things up a
little bit
anymore it's longer than the actual I
feel like one must be cold
pulling out like a big worm from
someone's leg you know as you did
pulling worms out of legs oh yeah
they're like parasite them yeah go for
some green tea key what colors the fluid
is it green no it's actually clear the
blue Tico's slightly blue tinge to it
but this this is clear
okay so we're going to turn off the
lights before we go to avoid any
flickering in the image and shoot all
this in 4k at a thousand frames a second
it's incredibly difficult to predict
where the focus is going to be so we'll
probably use a little pilot light from
the propane I'll try and see it it's
going to be so dull 1000 frames a second
at night but yeah I did my best
your dough
yep hit it okay let's test out the
greenery
whoa all the stuff weather
all right this is going to be very blown
out on this camera and we'll show the
process for firing four flags are
difficult into each other who knows all
this other life
yes test price
you won
it was really cool that was awesome I
really like that yeah so so like I was
surprised that you could see the
difference in the colors of the flames
because yeah especially between the red
and the orange yeah which you know very
similar in one of those shots you could
see the red book files slightly before
the origin and orange boiled up and
there was a clear difference between the
two colors and obviously the green in
the blue are just really vivid cool yeah
I just really liked that so I could
watch that forever kind of a new thing
like I like colored flames like things
hopefully you like that video they have
a nasty one but we'd have to blow stuff
up every week yes still don't do that
home go do that who knows our teams are
still dangerous he set the ground on
fire yeah a few times and Dan says hand
on fire no oh God not good fine fine
fine
well I was wearing gloves that's true so
don't do it
yeah from 10 - feel free to follow us on
Twitter buy a shirt German demo 7 lovely
believe it and most importantly as
always subscribe to our channel because
we will keep making slow-mo
as long as you keep watching